(lively music)
- Carhartt,
the company has been a
part of streetwear culture,
as long as streetwear has been around.
Drake, Rihanna, and Obama are
only a few of the big names
who have donned the brand.
- It's worn by folks
that might be wearing
Carhartt to tech jobs,
or might be wearing Carhartt
as they trade crypto on the daily.
- [Narrator] But Carhartt didn't
chase after this consumer.
And its popularity in fashion
has little to do with
the company's strategy.
In fact, the workwear brand strategy
has been rather consistent
across 134 years,
even while its competition changed course.
This is the economics of Carhartt.
(lively music)
When Carhartt
was founded in 1889,
(camera shutter clicks)
the American workforce looked
pretty different than today's.
At the turn of the century,
an estimated 38% worked on farms,
and 31% worked in mining,
manufacturing, and construction.
When a traveling salesman
(camera shutter clicks)
named, Hamilton Carhartt
asked railroad workers
how their uniforms could be improved,
he used his findings to create
the first Carhartt product,
(camera shutter clicks)
a pair of overalls.
- These are some of our
early styles of overalls
from the earliest years of the company.
- [Narrator] Overtime, Carhartt expanded.
- We start making work pants,
which at the time were
called waist overalls.
We started introducing jackets and coats.
- [Narrator] The overalls chore coat
and the double front pant,
laid the groundwork for Carhartt's brand,
and they've remained relatively unchanged.
- We always have those core products.
We always have that denim.
We always have that duck.
It's always gonna be something
that you're gonna be able to get from us.
Having that foundation
is what allows us to do
some of the experimentation we do.
(lively music)
- As the workforce evolved
and the number of railroad
workers and farmers dwindled,
experimentation was key.
(camera shutter clicks)
And Carhartt's consumers
gave the brand an idea.
Today, there is no article of clothing
that better represents Carhartt
than what's known internally
as the A18 Watch Hat, aka the beanie.
Google searches for
Carhartt and its beanie
have increased over recent years.
At 1999, the beanies are priced
as an entry point for
first-time customers,
and are a top-selling item
for the brand each year.
- Carhartt's popularity right now
is best described as this
thirst for authenticity.
This thirst for genuine clothing.
The way fashion works right now,
it's not necessarily that
one trend is super dominant.
Carhartt is finding purchase
with a lot of different
waves of trend right now.
- [Narrator] And it's not the first time
the family owned company
exploded into the mainstream.
♪ Jump around ♪
- [Narrator] In the '80s and '90s,
Dickies and Carhartt were
picked up by skateboarders
and famous rappers as streetwear.
- That had a trickle down effect.
Once rappers were wearing it,
then other people wanted it as well.
- [Narrator] Dickies
leaned into the attention.
On its Instagram page,
you'll find photos of
farmers and woodworkers,
but you'll also see a
lot of skateboarders.
Whereas Carhartt almost exclusively shows
people working in its clothes.
Dickies also expanded its product lines,
adding more options for skateboarders.
Today, it has a total of
159 men's pants and shorts,
and its original 874 work
pants come in 21 colors.
Carhartt, on the other hand,
sells 67 items under the men's
work pants in short section.
This includes items like jeans
and a single pair of sweatpants.
At most, it makes a pair
of pants in eight colors,
but many have between two to four options.
While Carhartt's websites and stores
are important for the company,
they're not yet the company's
biggest source of revenue.
Instead, the brand still relies heavily
on wholesale distribution
to other retailers,
like Tractor Supply,
Dick's Sporting Goods,
and Bass Pro Shops.
But recently, Carhartt explored
a new way to reach workers.
- So in 2018, we started
Carhartt company gear,
because there was a consumer need
to provide uniform that can be embellished
with different company's logos and names.
- [Narrator] Not long after,
it partnered with United Airlines
providing uniforms to 28,000 workers.
And in 2023, Carhartt
and "The Weather Channel"
announced a partnership.
While Carhartt has presented
an unwavering devotion to workwear,
there is a caveat.
Back in the late 1980s,
when streetwear took off,
a European retailer made
the company a proposal.
He'd take Carhartt's merchandise
and tweak it for a European audience.
Carhartt agreed.
And in 1989, all-American
concept was born.
Soon after it was renamed to
Carhartt Work In Progress.
As a licensee, Carhartt Work in Progress
caters to anyone interested in streetwear
and other apparel inspired by workwear.
And in 2011, it expanded to the US.
Importantly, Carhartt Work in Progress
still reports to Carhartt.
They make decisions together,
and Work in Progress' revenue
is a portion of Carhartt's.
- It's been really wonderful
to have the licensee
with Carhartt Work in Progress,
and it does allow them to
address a different consumer,
but it's still inspired by workwear.
So that allows Carhartt, for us,
to really focus in on
building the most durable
and versatile workwear for the job sites.
- Versatility is really
something that our consumer
has seemed to have created
kind of on their own.
We start off as this
workwear company, right?
And we, all of a sudden, you
know, see our stuff being used
in the outdoors, camping, hunting,
you know, all those other kinds of of uses
for like a rugged, heavy-duty product.
(camera shutter clicks)
- Seeing this
inspired Carhartt to
create a new product line
called Super Dux in the 1930s
(camera shutter clicks)
for all these other outdoor uses.
But this line didn't take off back then.
People already had outdoor
jackets from Carhartt,
their work jackets.
They didn't need another one.
Still, Carhartt learned something key.
It's workwear clothing was being used
for far more than just work.
Over the course of a few decades,
this revelation changed workwear
and the original companies that made it.
In the 1970s, Carhartt expanded
beyond outdoor apparel,
starting with a sweatshirt
- We can go out and make a
t-shirt, or make a beanie,
or maybe play around with some
sort of contemporary styles.
- [Narrator] This mindset
defined the company
over the century and helped to grow
even while many Americans pivoted
from working outdoors to offices.
- There were many workwear
manufacturers in America
at a certain time.
And a lot of them, for
a multitude of reasons,
have fallen away.
They don't exist anymore.
They've gone bankrupt.
They've been subsumed
by a different company,
and those clothes just
aren't existent anymore.
- [Narrator] Work and the way
people think about clothing
has changed significantly in 134 years.
But Carhartt hasn't.
- Just 'cause someone wears
something for a utilitarian job
doesn't mean they're not thinking
about how that product
looks on their body.
This kind of fashion consumer
and this function consumer,
I think they cross over
in a lot of places.
And, you know, you might
have the Carhartt jacket
'cause it looks really cool,
but then on a 30-degree day, you might be
really happy you have it.
(gentle music)